vous avez probablement entendu parler de
chat GPT sans trop savoir ce que c'est
eh ben le journaliste Gilda menu s'est
demandé si les plateformes
d'intelligence artificielle peuvent nous
aider à économiser à l'épicerie
[Musique]
et voilà
cette recette de ma fine a été
entièrement conçue grâce à
l'intelligence artificielle
c'est le robot conversationnel chat GPT
qui m'a permis de vider quelques
produits qui traînaient dans mon frigo
mais c'est délicieux
nous gaspillons 1300 dollars d'aliments
chaque année je me suis donc demandé si
l'intelligence artificielle peut nous
aider à économiser
chaque gipiti est arrivé dans nos vies
au mois de novembre dernier et là les
gens sont mis à l'utiliser l'utiliser et
voir à quel point c'était un monde
infini de possibilités je suis allé à la
rencontre d'un stratège en gestion de
Marc agroalimentaire qui s'intéresse de
près à l'intelligence artificielle c'est
quoi le buzz autour de l'intelligence
artificielle tchatche et en fait c'est
une intelligence artificielle générative
donc tu lui poses une question et il va
te générer la réponse
tu peux même lui demander de te proposer
une recette il va fouiller dans toute
l'information avec laquelle il a été
alimenté et de générer cette réponse là
il me dit même qu'elle est facile à
préparer
l'intelligence artificielle pourrait
révolutionner la façon dont nous
consommons à commencer par nous aider à
cuisiner nos aliments
qui traînent dans mon frigo oui parce
que le
j'ai demandé au chef consultant Bobby
Grégoire de tester le robot
conversationnel tchat GPT j'ai besoin
d'une suggestion de recette donc on
parlait tant de violon
après ça on avait avocat
les tomates cerises
la noix de coco on essaye
pratique mais par contre chat GPT ne
peut pas fouiller dans les circulaires
tchat GPT et utilise les données qui
date de 2021 et avant on doit nous-mêmes
faire la recherche des aliments en
spéciaux dans notre bannière préférée
par contre ça devient intéressant quand
vient le temps se poser la question de
bien conserver ses aliments ou
d'augmenter leur durée de vie donc
Hunter ce qui nous propose en fait c'est
une salade de têtes de violon avocat
tomates cerises concombres et noix de
coco
ce qui rajoute par contre comme
ingrédient qu'on n'a pas de sortie en ce
moment c'est le jeu d'un demi citron
vert donc une lime j'en ai pas assez
souvent dans le pot donc ça prend encore
acide là on pourrait lui demander en
question complémentaire qu'est-ce que tu
nous suggères pour remplacer la lime
j'ai envie de te dire que présentement
tchadjipiti le meilleur utilisation
c'est plus pour une base d'inspiration
qu'autre chose au niveau des recettes
est aussi le moteur de nouveaux services
en ligne qui veulent nous aider à
économiser
est le premier chef issu de
l'intelligence artificielle on l'a
programmé pour deux valeurs qui sont
fondamentales pour nous soit l'économie
d'épicerie ou l'économie d'argent et
aussi anti-gaspillage bonjour à tous
bienvenue sur chers Touski chef tout ce
qui a été lancé au printemps à Val d'Or
par l'entrepreneur Dave Tremblay c'est
un peu comme un chat GPT on peut lui
demander n'importe quoi la seule chose
c'est que ça allait un lien avec la
cuisine ça pas bien avec la cuisine il
nous répondra pas c'est vraiment un chef
à part entière la version gratuite
permet de consulter ce chef virtuel 10
fois par mois et contrairement à tchat
GPT il est programmé spécifiquement pour
nous aider à économiser tu vois les
tomates cerises sont quand même elles
sont avancées que faire avec des tomates
cerises ratatinées
tout ça l'huile d'olive n'est pas non
plus dans la recette de chef tout ce qui
alors qu'elle était sous celle de chaque
GPD
autre site Web cuisinons l'inflation qui
donne chaque semaine une idée des
promotions sur 400 ingrédients dans 10
chaînes d'épicerie et qui proposent des
recettes créées par l'intelligence
artificielle
à partir du budget de la taille de la
famille il y a du petit qui génère des
recettes et de notre côté on a une chef
une nutritionniste qui repense par
dessus pour s'assurer que c'est pas
juste l'intelligence artificielle mais
que ce soit des recettes qui font du
sens pour les Canadiens quelle est
l'avantage d'utiliser l'intelligence
artificielle c'est la rapidité parce que
on génère quand même 7 recettes par
semaine pour chaque panier
ce site internet permet de magaziner les
aliments en promotion et de les faire
livrer par skip Express Lane il est
offert dans certains secteurs d'une
quinzaine de villes canadiennes mais pas
encore au Québec il y a un outil comme
cuisine l'inflation et t'intéressant
dans une optique où il va nous dire quel
produit est moins cher que la semaine
précédente quel produit a augmenté par
rapport à la semaine précédente par
contre ils vont nous diriger vers une
seule source d'achat donc ce qui serait
vraiment intéressant que nous dit comme
ça c'est qu'il nous donne accès à aux
spéciaux de toutes les chaînes
d'épicerie disponibles et qui nous en
ligne vers la bonne chaîne pour avoir
les réaction des petits la moins chère
possible au bout de la semaine
pour l'instant il faut garder un oeil
critique sur les informations générées
par l'intelligence artificielle mais
cette technologie est là pour rester et
elle se perfectionne un rythme effréné
c'est intéressant notre coco on finit
avec la noix de coco
c'est un seul essai mais conclusions
c'est moins désert que je m'attendais
mais par contre on va clairement que
bien qu'il y a certaines notions de goût
par rapport à des traditions de recettes
la compréhension fine de c'est quoi
qu'est-ce qu'ils vont ensemble c'est
quoi les accords comment fonctionne les
molécules aromatiques on n'est pas là du
tout
moi je sens qu'on est au tout début
d'une grande Révolution lorsque les
intelligences artificielles vont être
connectés sur nos frigos sur nos gardes
manger et qui vont voir en temps réel
les produits qui nous restent en banque
qu'est-ce qu'on doit acheter là ça va
vraiment devenir un outil extraordinaire
parce qu'ils vont nous proposer sans
rien qu'on aille faire de requêtes ces
outils-là vont pouvoir nous proposer des
repas des solutions pour éviter
complètement gaspillage alimentaire